Although this scale can be useful for helping determining situations that may
be stressful, it's important to know that we can also experience many small
hassles throughout the day, and that can lead to stress. So the accumulation of
minor irritations, such as waking up late for work, getting stuck in traffic,
doing poorly on a test or even your significant other not calling you back. All
those things can add up and the result is stress. However, it's important to
note that what you may find stressful, I may not. Therefore, stress is what we
call an individual response. The important thing to remember here is that it's
the person's perceived ability to meet the demands of the situation. That
determine whether or not it's stressful. For example, what you may find
stressful, I may not. Now, this skill is used for, but it doesn't tell us
everything about every type of stressful situation. In addition there are some
items that are a bit outdated. For example, one item says, wife begins or stops
working. Nothing about a husband working, or a partner working, just a wife.
Now, this leads us to the second way to look at stress, and that is stress as a
response. When we see that everybody handles stress differently, we're talking
about how does that person handle stress, both psychologically, as well as
physiologically. Now we're going to go to Lauren, and look at the psychological
vantage point of how people handle stress.